Hello.
My name is
Charlie McDonnell,
and this is my
dance recess.
Thank you.
♪TECHNO MUSIC♪
MUSIC FINISHES
HEAVY BREATHING
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Thank you very much for
watching whatever that was.
This video was inspired by
Linda's video titled
"How to Take a Dance Recess,"
so you better watch that too.
Todd, who wrote this song,
is selling it on iTunes
if you'd like to purchase
it from him,
and maybe even do your own
little dance recess if you'd like to.
I think that'd be fun, but you are
by no means obliged.
Thank you for taking me
seriously as a filmmaker.
Goodbye.
♪TECHNO MUSIC♪